Các bạn có khi hình hoàn chình bị đón tích miền đàn bình gọi hai nghỉ khu chăm hai mì sau,
chứ khoang hình hai vị xin tham một bộ tư lệnh vùng một thay quân đã tổ chức gặp mặt các đại biểu của bệnh mối phòng viên.
Nên tập viên tự các thơ quan bảo xí trước giờ lên đường thực hiện những vụ tệ các tiến đạo phía bác của tổ quốc.
Đây không chỉ là một chuyến công tác mà còn là nhiều cầu nối lỉnh rất liền với hai đạo,
má theo hơi ẩm đất liền, tình cảm của nguyên dân cả nước đình với các cánh bộ,
chính sĩ và nhân dân người đầu sống họ,
những bút trên không ngoài của các anh chỉ phòng biên sẽ gì lại những khuẩn thác đón tích kiên cửa,
ấm á của quân sinh tụi biển đạo phía bác, đó là những thức phía,
máy vì trên thực hiện về tình yêu quên vương và chủ quyền đến đạo thiên liền.
Chúc đàn công tác có một chuyến đi thuật bộ xuy ra,
bởi qua sống giữ đệ mạc xin thuy đến với mọi nhà.
Chúc các chiến sĩ nơi đạo xa vẫn là mối tốn tài xuống,
giữ trọt mình ím trật tổ quốc.